[Musique]
bonsoir nozomi iyaz merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors cette
lettre des médecins la pétition de
journalistes de reporters sans
frontières
hier est ce que selon vous cela peut
peser avoir un impact sur le destin de
julian assange
je pense qu'il est important pour la
communauté internationale de comprendre
que les droits de julien assange chante
été volé par de nombreux gouvernements
occidentaux notamment par le running
julien un sens je n'ai pas accès à des
soins médicaux adéquats
il a également été soumis à des tortures
psychologiques selon le rapport du
spécialiste de l'ogn nice mais ça donc
c'est très important que les docteurs et
j'ai toutes les personnes qui se
préoccupent les bras de l'homme adopte
une position ferme
comment expliquer parce que les termes
forts effectivement parle de torture
psychologique ont décrit une privation
de lumière de soins médicaux de contact
avec le monde extérieur
une situation qui a duré plus d'un an
comment on explique les droits les plus
élémentaires dans des démocraties n'ait
pas été respectée sur la personne de
julian assange comment vous vous
l'expliquez vous qui connaissez
extrêmement bien ce dossier julien
assange récemment été placée dans un
isolement complet jusqu'à tout récemment
c'est le confinement solitaire et
reconnue au niveau international comme
en forme de torture aux d'autre part
simic sert à indiquer à qui j'ai reprise
que julien assange a montré le preuve
d'une personne et signe d'une personne
qui a été torturé il est ex président
pour les experts pour les spécialistes
que je viens 100 ch a bien été torturé
mais comment justement l'expliqué encore
une fois dans des démocraties où l'on
respecte le théoriquement est
normalement le les droits de l'homme les
plus élémentaires comment expliquer cela
replacé situation dans le contexte
ce journaliste a révélé des documents
gouvernementaux concernant les actions
des états unis dans des théâtres de
guerre et sans être inculpés il est à
égalité mais dans une prison à de
sécurité maximum à londres donc
effectivement cela pose des questions et
très grave de nos produits aux derbys
normalement deuxième démocratie un
journaliste ne serez jamais soumis un
tel traitement
effectivement cela est problématique et
montrent que nous ne pouvons pas
vraiment tenté société démocratique n'a
t'on pas vraiment la démocratie
nous n'avons pas la possibilité de faire
appel face à de telles violations des
lois l'audience approche au lundi 24
février une demande d'extradition
états unis j'ai une haine assange risque
vraiment lourd
à quoi faut-il s'attendre selon vous les
juges devraient reconnaître que ce cas
cette affaire à toute éthique politique
et qu'il n'y a pas de raisons légales et
que cause légale pour continuer le
processus d'extradition
j'espère que c'est la première journée
de cette audition qu'il jouera plusieurs
jours la sphère sera abandonnée et
julien assange sera libéré est ce que
vous pensez justement que cette pression
médiatique les journalistes les
pétitions des médecins un peu pesé sur
ce procès est ce que c'est un procès
selon vous qui va se tenir dans des
conditions sereines et est réellement
indépendante
je pense que c'est vraiment ici qu'on va
voir si nous vivons dans une société
juste ou pas et pour les personnes qui
s'intéressent à l'avenir du journalisme
il va falloir prêté beaucoup d'attention
à cette audience il commence la semaine
prochaine nous permettra de voir si nous
vivons dans une société démocratique ou
pas le fragiliser le gouvernement
britannique n'a pas pouvoir faire
exercer sur son indépendance juridique y
résister aux intérêts américains demain
et il est très clair que cette affaire
sera une preuve
un témoignage afin de savoir si le
vivons pas dans une
c'est démocratique et si le royaume uni
peut respecter ses propres idées cela
signifiera la fin de notre état de droit
merci beaucoup nos amis aya journaliste
auteur de wikileaks quatrième pouvoir
l'histoire en marche d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france